according to a new survey the u.s media
is the least
trustworthy in the world dead last think
about that the wealthiest nation by far
got creamed by places like finland
finland who just started getting the
news
a few months ago
[Laughter]
so will our media learn from this
humiliating result
no they buried it like stelter's
treadmill under six months of dirty
laundry
now i bashed the media a lot outside of
nude jazzercise it's my favorite thing
to do in front of an open window
see the media is almost wrong on
everything but like a middle school
soccer game
they don't like to keep score but i do
of course there's the wuhan lab lie both
the media and big tech buried that
claiming even mentioning it was more
racist
than sarah silverman justin trudeau and
ralph northam in blackface singing mammy
there's the ig report showing how the
media lied about the secret service
clearing lafayette park so trump could
have a photo op with the bible
cnn ran with that bs especially this guy
you're watching this video now the
president walking through
lafayette park the united states
government does not use the military
against civilians in this country unless
there's a damn good reason
and this just wasn't a damn good reason
and all we ended up with was what the
president of the united states looking
like
a wannabe dictator
if that guy got any slimier he'd be a
bowl of okra drooled on by a saint
bernard
remember when the new york times said
the first coveted vaccine wouldn't be
ready until november
2033 of course they said that while
trump was president so it served a
purpose i haven't seen a prediction that
wrong since i expected that cold sore to
go away
there's the media embracing jesse
smelled a story with more holes than a
golf course full of pool tables
and that's one of many instances where
the media played up hate crimes only to
bury
them later when they turn out to be
false you also remember all the final
nail in the coffin stories about trump
arrest is imminent they would cry and
then like the inside of joy reid's
head nothing it makes the worst case
scenario really palpable the worst case
scenario that the president is a foreign
agent many are saying this is a day that
will live
in infamy that's true they say it will
be remembered
as the day the presidency as a symbol of
america's protection
died the news is tightening around the
trump campaign it's activities
it's according to this evidence it's
attempts to get inside information and
according
to one email from mr stone to direct the
type of material information it wanted
to get
from wikileaks which is according to
mueller alleged to be originally from
russia what a delusion you remember when
the media joined together prior to a
national election to disappear the
hundred biden story to help their side
win
and then when it was safe and biden had
won the story just magically re-emerged
it's all about timing as even time
magazine brazenly admitted that the
media activist at big tech had joined
forces in manipulating narratives
and turmoil to sway an election crap
like joe biden talking about corn pop i
could go on forever
collusion obstruction kavanaugh
covington julie fricken sweat nick
michael frickin avenatti cnn slobbered
all over that litigating lollipop
remember the imminent slaughter of the
kurds or trump golfing when he was
really in afghanistan visiting the
troops how about russians putting
bounties on u.s troops under trump
or the non-stop about tax returns how
about when the phony bombshell book
anonymous was falsely claimed to have
been penned by a senior trump official
then you find out it was a nobody
remember the media's mockery of rising
crime after calling riots mostly
peaceful
those same people who defended looting
are now psyched that a granny was
sentenced for entering the capitol
building
and now they claim it's the republicans
not the democrats who want to defund the
police how rich
the media's made so many mistakes it
actually helps them
because like cats exes it's impossible
to keep track of all of them
[Laughter]
now when i slam the media people say but
greg you are the media
damn right i've been doing this for 30
years i've been all over mens mags
women's mags political journals
nudism advocacy that's how i met dr drew
but i was the odd man out a gorgeous
square
peg in an ugly stupid hole but that
meant i could watch the proverbial
sausage being made it was more
disgusting than watching a snuff film
so i've heard the pro the process
is built on gathering eyeballs not info
to make a profit you need a narrative so
you cover only certain facts in a way
that supports the preconceived view of
reality
a story that doesn't have a villain does
not rate a story that doesn't unfold
like a movie plot holds no interest for
the reporter
a story that doesn't make the reporter
feel important well
like the first draft of a jesse waters
book it always gets rewritten
and rewritten and rewritten
the media is a story making machine so
it's inherently false the narratives are
decided before the story is written
obama is good trump is bad sit on the
kids and cages photos from the obama
administration
report on them as though they were
trump's fault never correct the record
the narrative always trumps truth and
now reporters
must rely on the unstable crazies on
twitter for content
that's the thrust behind wokism and
cancel culture
the twitter hive is the only thing
keeping the media outrage machine afloat
can you imagine getting ideas from a
platform where the anonymous
mob rules it maintains fat salaries for
executives in legacy media but imagine
today being a young reporter all you do
is write about tweets from losers
local news is dead your story is judged
on clicks
so like a tick on a dog's nuts it has to
draw blood to survive
wow yeah so these young writers never
find satisfying work
the lowly twitter trend monkeys toil in
raging obscurity until the machine farts
them out
then they end up waiting on me at
restaurants which is good i never tip
less than 25 percent
welcome tonight's guests
she brings more to the table than a
waiter on net
the faulkner focus anchor harris [ __ ]
he believes in the mind-body connection
and i wouldn't mind having his body
oh some doctors doctor drew dr drew
pinsky
and she can light up a room with her
crack pipe
buster's contributor
and paul captain told him to pick on
someone his own size by massive sidekick
and joseph and upset on fox station
iris
oh i'm so excited to have you here
harris i'm excited to be here i mean uh
big fan you were one of the only people
who was nice to me back in the
good old days red eyes
they love me now harris back then they
didn't love me
oh they used to beat me in the halls
that's an expression they would throw
hot garbage on me anyway you report
unlike
the most media you report on facts every
day
why is it so hard for everyone else you
don't seem to come to something with a
preconceived narrative i
actually see you go what is the story i
i do ask it a lot because there's so
much out there now and with social media
everybody thinks that they can do my job
yes so what they do is they just slap a
little you know interesting lingo in
there
for instance this hour i had never heard
ticks dogs
balls farts one thing
i mean if people would bring it real
like that it would make my job a lot
easier but what i'm having to do when i
report on the focus every day is like
debunk all the stuff
yeah even get started and try to figure
out you know where's the truth that
people are
are hungry for because they do want it
yeah they do want people to be straight
with them you notice i have been
shifting a lot of the rhetoric on fox to
include such phrases
that you just mentioned like dogs nuts
and balls and things congratulations on
the five today do you know what i said
oh boy eat a bag of spotted dicks
which is a dessert dr drew um it may be
a dessert but no it's not what that
really jumps to mine it's a it's a bread
pudding
with currants and raisins i used to eat
it when i lived in london i was not a
fan of it dr
drew here's the problem with cnn and you
understand that cnn and all networks
they can't resolve the sunk costs of
their past
being wrong so if you're wrong for a
long time you either
stop turn around and start over or you
you just
pretend that it's a principle in being
wrong like you know what i've got to
maintain
consistency in my narrow-mindedness
because that's a principle
first of all when you said sunk cost you
afraid where you were going with that
talk but be that as it may um
there seems to be one thing about you
know today i was looking at a list of
all the things the press got wrong
and [ __ ] the sharon atkinson one that's
a good one that was an amazing list when
you see
38 pages yeah 38 pages and each one
you're like yeah i remember that that
was wrong that was wrong
and they never adjust course ever no
they can't
and to your point if you've ever been
the object of a story on twitter
harris you what you find is how fake
news develops you see it more
and then once the fake news is the more
juicy topic is sort of
becoming viral that gets reported as
fact
and it's a million miles from the truth
in almost every case
no it's true tyrus i think though we are
blessed with a smarter audience right
don't you think that our audience and i
mean generally fox
like oh these people are great ones here
they're amazing
i'm stuck here i don't want to support
his pandering but i don't want them mad
at me either so i'm just going to say
pass oh come on it's what you expect
[Laughter]
you know i love you
all of you guys so smart yes i
i refuse the play you know what
it's one of the biggest compliments that
i've gotten since i've
took this job was what would normally be
an insult in any other profession
you are blessed with common sense
he's a common sense god i
love that he's a c student
common is regular right guy
is the dude you don't marry no one said
i married that guy they married that man
like
literally just being room temperature
and telling it
without any bells and whistles is
amazing
here's the here's the secret we all can
do it it's
common sense right and if you don't have
common sense you really shouldn't be
talking but but it's rare now it's crazy
we're hysterical instead of
having common sense so common sense is
something we crave and attract you don't
get clicks
common sense that's true that's not true
i just went viral with common sense
if you hate the flag why participate
right i was common sense researching
this
topic on google and i saw
a headline on the economist that said
trust in the media has increased in the
past year
then you have to click on it to see the
subhead that says in countries other
than america
that is right yeah like they're writing
about
this and they can't not do this
as they're writing about it exactly
they're lying about the thing that's
accusing them of lying
yeah but i mean if you if you look at
what people want
they want to be entertained yeah so if
you're if you're not
lighting it up they don't really want to
participate
and you don't need to oversell the truth
to tyrus's point
common sense the facts you don't need to
oversee you don't have to shout
a building's on fire unless you're
actually at the scene trying to save
lives
like if you're in a studio or if you're
on twitter you don't need
nine zillion exclamation points with the
truth the truth is what it is it sells
itself
yes and the truth i think i'm going to
point a phrase here is out there
i just came up with that guys well if
fox the truth is in here yes
i i would say greg nash it
not [ __ ] that's my new my new diet show
nauseous dude that's not what i thought
anywhere
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else